we're asked to multiply 65 times 1. so
literally we just need to multiply 65
and we could write it as a
times sign like that or we could write
it as a dot like that but this means 65
times one and there's two ways to
interpret it interpret this you could
view this as the number 65
one time or you could view this as a
number one 65 times all added up but
either way if you if you have 165
this is literally just going to be 65
anything times 1 is going to be that
anything whatever this is
whatever this is times 1 is going to be
that same thing again if i have if i
have
you could think of well if i had just
some kind of placeholder here
times one
times one and i could even write it as
the time symbol times one that's going
to be that same placeholder
that's going to be that same placeholder
so if i have 3 times 1 i'm going to get
3. if i have
if i have 5 times 1 i'm going to get 5
because literally all this is saying is
5 one time
if i get if i put i don't know a hundred
and fifty seven times one that'll be 157
i think you get the idea